this declaration of results of Paul
during county election of a Member of
Parliament for Northwestern held on
Thursday 8 13 2017 I Terry Collins being
the acting returned officer at the
election do hereby give notice that the
number of ports recorded for each
candidate up Direction is as follows
breeze alum john UK Independence Party
[Music]
2150 Hart
Sarah Anne the Conservative Party
candidates sixteen thousand five hundred
and sixteen awesome Dominic Clare James
the Green Party 530 pitcock Laura lever
party 25,000
[Applause]
and temple or in Layton Liberal
Democrats
3398 the number of pulpit was issued was
forty seven thousand nine hundred and
seventy-three
the turnout was sixty six point six five
percent and I do hereby declare that
Laura bit [ __ ] is duly elected
[Applause]
[Music]
couldíve then i thank you to the police
the returning officer thank you to all
of the staff who have worked furiously a
massive thank you to the Labor Party and
to Susan Dunn Worth who worked as very
very hard in the campaign thank you to
Andy plant what would I have done
without you and you've been phenomenal
and thank you to my brother my sister at
my niece's my partner Daniel and thank
you very much to my mom and dad the best
socialists and most hard-working people
I have ever met my dad concealed until
today that he had cracked a rib on this
campaign and not told anybody and your
unconditional love and unremitting faith
is just phenomenal thank you for
bringing me up in a political household
and making me believe in the power of
collective action I've never worked on
such a hard and and positive but hopeful
campaign and to every single activist in
this room and at home you will never
ever know how much I truly appreciate
and I'm in awe at your commitment and
what you did for this campaign thank you
to my wonderful union Unite and to the
strength determination and power of
Jeremy Corbyn the leader of the Labour
Party
and lastly check every single person in
this constituency who place their faith
in me thank you I will from this day be
a representative of all people and we
won this seat because we fought with
really hard work with hope with
determination and I just want to say to
the people out there who are suffering
who are really suffering under
conservative rule the tide is turning
and the word
[Music]